una infusión de té tiene la forma de una
pirámide rectangular de 7.9 centímetros
de alto tiene una base de 3.0
centímetros de largo y 1.5 centímetros
de ancho para preparar el mejor té el
infusor debe estar lleno de té al 80%
cuál es el volumen de té en centímetros
cúbicos necesario para llenar el infusor
al 80 por ciento de su capacidad
redondea a la décima más cercana muy
bien éste infusor de té parece algo
sofisticado con forma piramidal por lo
que se ve más o menos así tiene una base
de 3 centímetros por 1.5 centímetros
digamos que esto es 3 centímetros y esto
es 1.5 centímetros esta es su base la
dibujamos y etiquetamos y nos dicen que
tiene 7 puntos 9 centímetros de alto si
partimos del centro hacia arriba tiene 7
puntos 9 centímetros de alto es una
pirámide rectangular podríamos pensar en
las pirámides de egipto aunque ésta es
un poco más alta con respecto a su base
ya hayan visto estos elegantes infusores
de té lucen más o menos así lo que
podemos hacer primero es encontrar el
volumen de esta pirámide rectangular y
luego nos dicen que debe estar llena al
80% con té tenemos que calcular cuál es
el 80 por ciento de su volumen y esto
nos dirá cuál es el volumen de té
necesario para llenar el infusor al 80
por ciento de su capacidad y quizás se
pregunten cómo calcular el volumen de
una pirámide rectangular es justo lo que
les voy a decir hay una fórmula que no
voy a demostrar en este momento
especialmente si se encuentran en plena
realización de un examen no hay tiempo
para demostraciones pero la fórmula es
extrañamente intuitiva se multiplica el
área de la base por la altura y luego se
divide entre 3 cuál es el área de la
base pues es el largo por el ancho y
luego multiplicamos esto por la altura
el volumen es igual al largo por el
ancho por la altura y luego se divide
entre 3 otra forma de pensar en esto del
largo por el ancho es que
el área de esta base que luego se
multiplica por la altura y al final se
divide entre 3 si no lo dividiéramos
entre 3 tendríamos el volumen de un
prisma rectangular que contendría la
pirámide pero no nos preguntan por el
prisma rectangular sino por el volumen
de la pirámide rectangular esto va a ser
igual al largo que es 3 centímetros por
el ancho que es de 1.5 centímetros por
la altura que es de 7 puntos 9
centímetros
todo esto dividido entre 3 este 3 entre
3 es igual a 1 tenemos centímetros por
centímetros por centímetros lo que da
centímetros cúbicos por lo que el
volumen es igual a 1.5 x 7.9 centímetros
cúbicos o centímetros al cubo
este es el volumen total de la pirámide
rectangular de este elegante infusor dt
pero queremos conocer cuál es el 80 por
ciento de su capacidad que es la
cantidad de té que necesitamos queremos
multiplicar esto por 80 % multiplicamos
0.8 por 1.5 por 7
punto 9 centímetros cúbicos veamos 0.8 x
1.5 va a ser igual a 1.2 x 7.9
centímetros cúbicos podemos tratar de
aproximar esto de hecho esta opción luce
bastante aproximada pero podemos usar
una calculadora aquí vamos a hacerlo 1.2
x 7.9 es igual a 9.48 y si la
redondeamos a la décima más cercana la
redondeamos hacia arriba por este 8 de
aquí y queda como un 9.5 que es
justamente esta opción de aquí